Now let's look at several
attacks on the web.
The first is the cross-site
scripting attack.
Many websites allow
user to input data and
then simply display or echo data back.
The website include the user input data
in the HTML page to the user's browser,
such websites include social
networking sites, blogs, etc.
But what if the users are attackers,
and the user input is malicious?
Let's use an example to illustrate.
Suppose a website echoes
the user-supplied data, such as name,
back to the user.
Suppose user Joe visits a website,
and he supplies his name, Joe,
to the website, then the website will
send back a page saying, hello Joe.
Now, suppose,
instead of sending the user's name,
Joe, to the website,
the browser sends a script as his name.
What's going to happen?
The website will take this
script as the user's name and
echo it back to the web browser.
That is the script will be included
in the HTML page sent to the browser.
Therefore, when the browser displays
this webpage, the script will run,
the webpage will display Hello World.
Now, this is a benign case.
Now what if the script is malicious?
When the browser gets the HTML
page from the web server,
it would just execute the script.
So if the script is malicious,
then the malicious script will
be executed by the browser.
But why would the browser send
a malicious script to the website
without a user knowing about it?
How can this happen?